Neste capítulo vamos fornecer o framework
para pensar sobre ambientes computacionais
que podem ser aplicados tanto no seu laptop
quanto escalados até supercomputadores
ao final deste capítulo
você vai entender o conceito fundamental de recursos computacionais
e como eles se relacionam entre si
então o que são recursos computacionais simplesmente
são os componentes que formam um sistema computacional
temos a CPU ou unidade central de processamento
que executa a maioria das instruções, temos a memória
ou RAM que armazena temporariamente dados
e instruções do programa
e temos as GPUs ou unidades de processamento gráfico
que são projetadas para renderização gráfica
mas também podem ser usadas para tarefas de computação de uso geral
que exigem muito processamento paralelo
como simulação científica, análise de dados ou aprendizado de máquina
esses recursos trabalham juntos para executar programas
e cada um tem suas próprias unidades de medida
por exemplo as unidades de CPU são medidas em núcleos
e velocidade de clock, enquanto a memória é medida em bytes
em giga, mega e terabytes
para cada um dos nossos problemas
vamos precisar de um conjunto de recursos
para executá-los
é fundamental considerar os recursos necessários para executá-los
de forma eficiente; o local onde os componentes do programa são executados
e a largura de banda da infraestrutura que os conecta
têm um papel significativo
na determinação do desempenho geral
por exemplo uma GPU pode ser mais rápida para computar partes específicas
do nosso programa, mas se carregar o programa na memória da GPU
levar mais tempo do que economiza
pode ser mais rápido usar a CPU no lugar disso. Agora
vamos falar sobre escalabilidade de recursos clássicos
temos duas abordagens: escalonamento vertical
e escalonamento horizontal. O escalonamento vertical envolve aumentar
o poder de um único recurso
como usar uma CPU mais potente ou mais memória
dentro de um único nó físico
onde nó é uma unidade de cluster de computação que encapsula múltiplos
recursos dentro dele. O escalonamento horizontal
envolve adicionar mais recursos
como múltiplas CPUs ou GPUs
para trabalhar juntos em um único nó ou em múltiplos nós
ambas as abordagens têm suas próprias vantagens
e desvantagens, e a escolha depende do caso de uso específico
e dos requisitos. Vamos apresentar um novo tipo de recurso:
recursos quânticos. Recursos quânticos processam informação quântica
com uma unidade de processamento quântico ou QPU. Uma QPU
é o sistema completo responsável
por aceitar um conjunto de instruções quânticas executáveis
ou um quantum circuit e retornar
uma resposta precisa. Isso significa
que a QPU inclui um ou mais chips quânticos
por exemplo um processador quântico IBM
além de múltiplos componentes adicionais
em um refrigerador de diluição
que resfria o chip quântico
como amplificadores quânticos, eletrônica de controle
e o computador clássico necessário
para tarefas como armazenar instruções
e formas de onda na memória, acumular resultados
e a futura decodificação de correção de erros
em geral os recursos quânticos são medidos
em termos de sua qualidade na escala de fidelidade em camadas
o número de qubits
e a velocidade das operações de camada de circuit por
segundo ou CLOPS. Hoje vamos tratar o chip quântico
como uma unidade de medida, de forma semelhante a como os sistemas de gerenciamento de recursos
tratam as GPUs: não pelo número de núcleos
mas pela unidade inteira. E quanto ao escalonamento?
Assim como os recursos clássicos, o escalonamento de recursos quânticos pode
também ser categorizado em vertical
e horizontal. O escalonamento vertical
seria aumentar o número de qubits por chiplet
ou por chip
o escalonamento horizontal seria conectar chips
com acopladores ou com interconexões clássicas
com essa definição em mente
vamos falar sobre gerenciamento de recursos
gerenciamento de recursos em infraestrutura computacional refere-se
ao processo de planejar
alocar e controlar o uso de recursos computacionais
como CPU, memória, armazenamento
e largura de banda de rede para garantir
uma utilização de recursos eficiente e eficaz
você pode pensar no gerenciamento de recursos
como um jogo multidimensional de Tetris onde os blocos
são os requisitos dos seus jobs
e cada dimensão é uma unidade de recurso. A tarefa geral
é encaixar esses blocos de jobs em um cubo
de todos os seus recursos disponíveis. O gerenciamento de recursos
é uma tarefa muito complexa e diferentes instalações de computação implementam
diferentes estratégias para configurar sua infraestrutura
para as necessidades específicas de sua base de usuários
para aplicar os conceitos que acabamos de aprender, vamos usar
o Slurm. O Slurm é um software de código aberto
para gerenciamento de recursos
para fins de demonstração
tenho uma configuração local com três nós virtuais
podemos obter informações sobre esses recursos computacionais
executando o comando scontrol
teremos duas partições ou grupos de nós:
normal e quantum. A partição normal é composta de nós
que têm acesso apenas a recursos clássicos
e a partição quantum tem acesso a recursos quânticos
vamos primeiro executar o simples
exemplo clássico de hello world com o Slurm
primeiro precisamos do próprio programa hello world.
E aqui está nosso programa que simplesmente imprime hello
world.
Agora precisamos informar ao gerenciador de recursos
quais recursos precisamos para executar este programa
como discutimos, o Slurm fornece uma maneira de especificar
todos os metadados de um job por meio de
um script shell
com algumas anotações específicas do Slurm
essas anotações permitem especificar os requisitos de recursos
parâmetros de agendamento e mais.
Podemos verificar nosso script de submissão
e aqui você tem a especificação da partição
quantos nós precisamos, quantas tarefas por nó vamos
executar, quantas CPUs por tarefa vamos usar
e qual script queremos executar
e este é nosso programa hello world.
Para submeter nosso job para execução só precisamos executar
um comando que é o sbatch
e fornecer nosso script como argumento
podemos verificar a fila de execução
e ver que nosso programa hello world está em execução
na partição normal no nó c1
quando o job terminar podemos verificar os resultados
consultando o arquivo de saída.
E é isso.
Também temos interesse em usar recursos quânticos
portanto vamos criar um programa simples de hello Qiskit.
Aqui está nosso programa Qiskit que tem todas as
etapas necessárias de criação de circuit
otimização, execução e pós-processamento.
E aqui estão todos os conceitos de programação que discutimos
sobre quantum circuit, transpiler
e primitivas do Qiskit
agora precisamos criar o script de submissão
como antes, mas aqui especificamos
os requisitos de recursos quânticos
como especificamos os recursos
e a partição do cluster
quais recursos quânticos estão disponíveis
as primitivas do Qiskit vão usar
os recursos alocados para executar os jobs quânticos.
Agora precisamos executar nosso programa.
E quando o job terminar podemos verificar os resultados.
E aqui está o nosso valor de expectativa.
E é isso para gerenciamento de recursos
na próxima seção vamos falar
sobre modelos de programação